start with a crisis in the karabakh
region of Azerbaijan nearly all the
estimated 120 000 ethnic Armenians
living there have now fled to Armenia
only a fraction have been left behind
the Town Square in Hunt candy also known
as the panicert is now deserted shops
homes and businesses have been abandoned
azerbaijani forces have taken full
control of the enclave and they've
started installing road signs with new
names let's go live to Al jazeera's
Osama bin Javed who joins us from Khan
candy the main city in karabach just set
the scene for us Osama tell us about
where you are and what it's like
Folly you've been seeing pictures from
Han candy in the last few days tens of
thousands of people who had lined up the
square with all that was they could
carry with them people who were in their
cars were queuing up to leave outside
and and leave the city but people who
were here were waiting for buses for
their relatives for others to come and
take them with them as they did not
believe the assurances that were given
by the azerbaijani government that they
will not be prosecuted here in the Town
Center if I go quiet you'd be able to
hear nothing there is absolutely no one
who's left here apart from a few elderly
uh disabled and others we did see some
Red Cross workers who were here earlier
who were taking people ferrying them
away and taking them to a staging point
from where they're going to take them
into Armenia that's what people want hey
here let me just show you here are some
puppies who've been following us around
possibly looking for food this is this
is a hard to describe feeling on when
you enter a town where you've been
looking at pictures of it where there
was so much activity but now there's
nobody here people have left with
whatever there was they've left the the
cheered cups they were drinking from
they've left their children's strollers
all you can see are chairs here is a
makeshift stove that they built so that
they can have enjoy some warmth because
it gets cold in the evening but this is
how we're seeing open pieces of luggage
people who couldn't carry things with
them uh have left them behind so here's
what this looks like a ghost town which
seems to have no soul left it's quite
incredible what you're showing us there
through your camera Osama as you say it
looks like a ghost town but most
importantly it looks like people left in
a rush you know the strollers seeing
some of the strollers there and the
Animals there this was really a rushed
uh Exodus it would seem
it does appear to be that way as as
we've been driving through this town
we've looked at open shutters we've left
it uh We've looked at cars where doors
are open so it does feel like this was
an exodus it feels like where people
thought that they are they have to leave
as quick as they can although we were
hearing when we were outside of Han
kindy from azerbaijani officials that
they they're free to stay they they have
nothing to fear but you have to
understand the history of the last three
decades as well because there's been so
much hatred so much violence there's
been so much that has gone on between
these two sides that it was difficult
for people to imagine what peace between
the two sides would look like and as you
can see as you said it does appear that
people just up and left leaving
everything behind them
way you are now has been
hand candy it used to be known as the
panicker of course and that's happening
to other areas within the Karbach region
the azeris are renaming all these
different towns now
yes so the context of this is 30 years
ago when Armenian forces came in they
renamed all of these areas with Armenian
names this used to be known as Khan
kindy other places like hojalay and
kalbajar were also named with
azerbaijani names but they were changed
once Armenian forces took control of
these areas and a self-declared state
came into place but now azerbaijanis
have come into uh administrative
administrative control we've also been
seeing ambulances to give make sure that
there is some some sort of relief for
people we met the icrc we asked them and
they said that it is going to help them
to ensure that the people who were left
behind have uh some essential services
available the electricity but you can
see the lights are still running right
the water is still running although Aid
workers tell us that they can't be sure
of who are who the people who used to
run the water supply are no longer here
and behind us uh is now the vehicle is
left is where the Russian peacekeepers
were stationed because this was it was a
staging point where people were
gathering and leaving but this is what a
City without people looks like it is
scenes that we have never seen before
where such a huge massive population got
up and left leaving all that they could
leave behind with them and just taking
their memories and all they could pack
on their cars with them a City without
people you say Osama
what does the azerbaijani government and
the authorities say what are they
planning on doing with this city and
this region now that the entire
population they would see him has left
but what has been happening here is a
lot of development as you know that
there was a war but in 2020 where a lot
of this area was taken over by
azerbaijani officials so on the way here
as we came here three years ago and
there were hardly any roads they were
hardly uh any streets that were properly
built but on the way to Han Kandi in
shusha and other areas uh there have
been a lot of development in this area
so Azerbaijan says that it is going to
build infrastructure and that is why
officials who we've been speaking to
have been telling us that they would
like people to stay they would want
people to stay they wanted them to be
part of what is going to be a rebuilding
of this area a massive investment in
this area is what they call us but again
it is going to be an azerbaijani version
of it yes there are 120 000 people
who've left from this area but those
officials tell us that this is an area
which was home to more than a million
azerbaijanis who had to leave their
homes 30 years ago so now they're going
to make preparations for them to come
back and all those people from the
ethnic Armenian Community Who Remain
here are going to live side by side with
them as azerbaijani Citizens now you saw
the UN Mission that's made its way to
the Karbach region tell us about what
what they're there to do exactly what is
their mission
the United Nations has been allowed
access according to the azerbaijani
foreign Misty after three decades in
this area because they wanted to show
the United Nations what Azerbaijan calls
occupation destruction and illegal
settlement building and the U.N Mission
has been here to assess uh what
Azerbaijan wanted to show they will also
assess the needs of the people on the
ground we saw them leave this area so
I'm not sure how much assessment they
were able to do uh on the ground
themselves but we've been speaking to
Aid workers who've been here but again
because they're not that many people
left so assessing the humanitarian need
of an non-existent population seems like
a futile task so it we will wait to hear
from what the union U.N Mission found
what they saw what they plan to do with
this area but Azerbaijan says that it is
adamant to allow whoever wants to come
here and see for themselves that this is
an area which is open for people to live
and it is going to be secure at least
for now because the conflict has ended
and azerbaijani control our forces are
going to be in control of not just the
border of the step the city of Han Kandi
and the nagorno-karabakh region but also
all the way to the Latin Corridor and
the Border uh with Armenia as well we
did hear some reports uh earlier in the
day from Witnesses who described scenes
and and accused azerbaijani forces of
excesses and forced displacement but
everyone we've spoken to here in this
city including the icrc workers they
tell us they've found a no real cases
where people were actually forced out of
their homes or had to face any abuse or
trampling on their rights by by these
forces but again this is early days we
are the only crew which are here apart
from horses and dogs and a few Armenians
who are packing their things and getting
ready to leave there's nobody here
nobody there if you're just joining us
on Al Jazeera exclusive access to uh the
town is and city of Khan candy without
jazeeres Osama bin Javid one of the
first journalists to reach that town in
the Karbach region of Azerbaijan and
from what you can see from osama's
images there a ghost town an empty town
where nearly half all of the population
in fact has now fled to Armenia the
ethnic Armenian population of the
karabakh region Osama you were telling
us that the azerbaijani authorities
the plan they have for this region now
is to have azeries and ethnic Armenians
living side by side but as we've said
and we've been reporting on Al Jazeera
for a number of days now almost all the
ethnic Armenians have fled to Armenia
and the question now is would they ever
want to come back to this region what
assurances is the Azerbaijan government
giving them to perhaps make them want to
return one day
well that is the big question isn't it
that as you see what is around us it
feels that people have abandoned not
just a city but also hope it appears
that people have left in a way where
they don't see a future coming back to
this area where they feel that they have
had to leave and uproot themselves once
again and go towards an uncertain future
and that is why it is going to be
extremely important for azerbaijani
forces to make sure and the
administration to make sure that the
people who are here have the confidence
to live live here side by side as
azerbaijani Citizens with full rights
but the question about the right to
return is probably going to be addressed
in the next few weeks and months because
Azerbaijan says that the right to return
immediately the immediacy of the right
to return is with the azerbaijani
population which was uprooted 30 years
ago so there's a mass of demining
operation you have to realize that
almost a million hectares is estimated
to be contaminated with unexploded
munition mines and remnants of the war
so that has to be cleared out roads and
infrastructure pipelines have to be made
there has to be administrative control
bodies have to be set up to allow people
to to come back to these areas so the
right to return for the azerbaijani
population in in what we've been
speaking to officials is probably going
to be addressed first but they also have
set up a portal where people will be
able to register themselves the ethnic
Armenians should be able to register
themselves there's a special working
group that has been set up with
azerbaijani officials in charge to make
sure that these people will have
economic they they will have social and
they'll have humanitarian needs who will
be addressed but again this is early
days this is the first pictures that
you're seeing from this town which until
a few days ago was bustling with people
first exclusive pictures from Al
jazeera's Osama bin Javid in the
karabakh region of Azerbaijan reporting
there live from Khan candy which was
previously known as stefaniker Osama
thank you very much for your Excellence
reporting thank you a United Nations
mission is visiting The Enclave to
determine the humanitarian needs of the
remaining residents joining us now on
the NewsHour is Marco Suchi who's the
rapid deployment standing team manager
at the international Committee of the
Red Cross thank you for joining us from
Khan candy also known as Stephanie Kirk
in karabakh thank you uh can you tell us
first your initial assessment of the
situation there it's a very desolate
scene behind you in that City what's the
humanitarian situation like
good afternoon yes as you as you know
since the military escalation last week
a dozen of thousands of people have been
Crossing into into Armenia and this
queer that you see behind me is better
representative is reflecting what is
happening so most of the population Nets
left hospitals are empty
water board are not a Personnel also
left the director of the morgue also
left
our main concerns is of course looking
after the most vulnerable and helping in
particular the wounded
in the treatment or being evacuated who
is left in the city Marco
exactly exactly the people we are
concerned about I mean the elderly the
disabled those who don't have any family
relative and that's exactly what we are
looking for we have several teams that
since days are going house to house
trying to find they need and assistance
those with a medical condition have been
evacuated in cooperation with all the
authorities including Azerbaijan Armenia
the de facto authorities and of course
the Russians Keepers do you have a sense
of how many people are left there and
what their needs are right now you say
of course you're looking after the most
vulnerable You're looking for the most
vulnerable what are the needs on the
ground right now
yeah
it's difficult to estimate how many
people have left in the city for sure
what we can see the touring this city is
a
self-explanatory maybe a few hundreds
people have left and with the social
services still working for the time
being but the Healthcare System
completely
not collapsing but without any any
Personnel is of course this represents a
major need for the population remaining
here also the needs to connect those who
left
who are left in the city in the region
with their family relatives that's
another major needs so re-establishing
the family links the missing during the
last military escalation that's another
concern I didn't matter they need
the food provision
medicine medical supplies for those
remaining are of course among their
priorities for us yeah those are the
priorities for you as you say a few
hundred people left there can you give
us a sense of what sort of cooperation
and how you're working with the local
authorities the azerbaijani authorities
in making sure that these people are
taken care of
ICC have been in in the region for the
last at least three decades so we have
always been cooperating with all
concerned authorities and we are
cooperating will be cooperating in the
near future to make sure all the
humanitarian needs are met so we don't
see any any issue in that regard
what we are concerned about is as I said
that the most vulnerable are not left
behind those who have been separated by
their loved ones those who remain in
town that disabled the elderly
and the wounded so we are here exactly
for that reason
and we are among if not the only
humanitarian organization in the region
so it's a crucial it's critical that we
keep doing our job thank you so much Mr
tsuchi for taking the time to speak to
us about the situation there in the
karabakh region marcosuchi is from the
international Committee of the Red Cross
joining us there from Khan candy